aaron rodgers will have no sympathy for
tom brady
he doesn't have his top receivers either
and he just makes it keep happening
and he he he had another great game and
he's having a great season
and i am becoming more and more of an
aaron rodgers fan
every day and i've got my history with
aaron rodgers and i've criticized him in
the past and i've tried to
read between the tea leaves as chris
sims would say on
things that rogers has said and done and
i feel like at times he's passive
aggressive and he tries to prove a point
but he doesn't want to
be perceived as someone who's making a
problem
here he is from pat mcafee's show a
quote
that that may be ultimately when we look
back on the season one of the quotes of
the year he is
the whole conversation was like he's
bagged out he's this was the
did you hear that stuff i would assume
you did you have to in the world that
we're in that
you you see it every single day and do
you think
being a second year in your offense that
you're currently in with the floor is a
massive advantage to maybe what was
happening last year
okay i mean i don't know every every
team is different every year is
different and
you know circumstances in in any year
which allow you to have more success or
or make it more difficult for success
just kind of depends on the situation
um it does help be in the second year
for sure i feel a lot more comfortable
but you know i i sometimes laugh when
people talk about
you know down years for me because a lot
of times down years for me are career
years for most courses
that's quite a reaction from pat mcafee
and aj hawk to that comment from
aaron rodgers but he's right he's right
he delivered it very flat very deadpan
unexpected
the tail end of a very well reasoned
explanation and aaron jones told me
after their week two win over the lions
that that's why the team is better
they're definitely better than last year
because they know the offense better
they know the nuances they know how to
run it they know what's expected they
know the concepts etc
but yeah a little savage move there by
aaron rodgers and
and i like that i like that we're seeing
that from him
late in his career and who knows how
late it really is in his career the way
he's been moving the way he's been
throwing
maybe he can play into his 40s like tom
brady and drew brees
he looks like he's having fun and and i
don't know if i've seen that in a few
years from him you know the last time he
won the mvp award was 20 to
2014 but he did play awfully well i
thought last season i mean this is a
team that went 13-3 and you look at
their weapons and
maybe they're not as great as some other
quarterbacks have but he always has
elevated his receivers but he passed for
four thousand yards four thousand and
two he had 26 touchdowns he threw only
four interceptions
the stat heads the analytics gurus
didn't like it because there were too
many throwaways
the expected points added whatever that
is was not
good enough for for aaron rodgers the
bottom line was this was a team that
went 13-3 they go out they draft jordan
love and we know what kind of chip aaron
rodgers carries on his shoulder
and that ship got bigger and bigger when
they went out and traded
and it traded up to draft jordan love i
guarantee you and he's off to his
best start ever of his career he's on on
pace to set
a personal goal a personal record for
yards and for touchdowns this season so
he's having a great season when we talk
about the mvp award again
his name's definitely in that group
yeah i i agree with you completely and
something sims and i were talking about
earlier today mark murphy the ceo of the
team
may be some sort of a mad scientist
because last year murphy's reaction
to the excellent article from tyler dunn
then a bleacher report regarding
dysfunction between
aaron rodgers and former coach mike
mccarthy
murphy's reaction was along the lines of
maybe this will be good
maybe this will get some people pissed
off maybe this will benefit the team
if the reaction to this is we're not
happy
with the way things are being portrayed
and when the packers trade up give up a
fourth round pick to move up in round
one
to get jordan love it wasn't a falling
star like aaron rodgers it wasn't tua
making his way into the 20s
this was a project of a quarterback they
traded up to get
yes it gives them some security for the
future in the event that aaron rodgers
retires prematurely or his performance
drops off a cliff but it also in the
short term
applies that red hot poker as sims would
say to the rear end of aaron rodgers and
it gets him pissed off and it gets him
motivated and it gets him determined and
you know mission accomplished mark
murphy
if they were thinking about that at all
shireen because it's worked
and we've seen a better aaron rodgers
than we saw last year even though the
one last year
was better than most career pretty good
years for any quarterback
we're still seeing a better one this
year yeah
that we certainly are and you know he's
won two mvp awards and
looks like he's gonna be in that race to
to win a third mvp award you know you
look at what josh allen's done and
russell wilson and some others
but he's right there i mean he's just
putting up great numbers no
interceptions that to me stands out as
much as anything and you know forget
last year all the throwaways everything
else he's not losing
the football so he's not losing games
for his team and it doesn't matter who
he has out there at receiver
they just keep rolling keep putting up
yards keep scoring touch i mean who
would have taught
thought robert tanyan would have scored
three touchdowns in a game ever
and he did it last night and just kept
finding the open guy and i think that
goes back to just aaron rodgers
greatness and we just have to
appreciate that we're seeing probably
the last few years of aaron rodgers and
drew brees and tom brady and this has
been a golden era of quarterbacks
there's no question about that
best way to run the offense throw it to
the open guy don't get caught up in
who you want to get it to just get it to
whoever's open and trust him to make the
catch and the players are coming through
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports